after four days of rioting
south african president sula maposa
appeared on television appealing for
calm
although these may be opportunistic acts
of
looting driven by hardship and poverty
the poor and the marginalized bear the
ultimate brunt of the destruction that
is
currently underway
as i said shops have been looted and
infrastructure has been destroyed
the violence was sparked by the
imprisonment of former president jacob
zuma
he's been jailed for 15 months for
contempt of court
after not complying with an inquiry into
corruption
he's applied to the constitutional court
to review the sentence it imposed
saying it's unconstitutional many of
zuma's supporters say he's been jailed
unfairly
and they've taken to the streets to
voice their anger
but the government says what began as
support for zuma in the kwazulu-natal
province
is now being driven by crime at this
mall in soweto south of johannesburg
police are powerless as thousands of
people descend
grabbing whatever they can many of these
stores have been ransacked
and the police that we've spoken to here
have said they simply don't have enough
resources in fact they've been
pushed back by these looters some of
them stationed
within the car park as soon as any of
the looters are apprehended by police
rocks are thrown and police have to
leave
at least six people have been killed and
more than 500 arrested the unrest has
caused public services in some areas to
be suspended
including covert 19 vaccination programs
and now the military is being sent in to
help overwhelmed police
it's not certain how long the army will
have to be deployed
but there are concerns that a high
unemployment rate
worsened by a strict covet 19 lockdown
is contributing to the violence
and while boots on the ground may quell
violence for now
south africa's economic and political
problems
may run far deeper familia miller al
jazeera johannesburg